[Music]
jennifer lopez looking oh so bridal and
it just turned out to be something
really magical the singer stunned at the
2021 american music awards with a
performance of her latest single on my
way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lopez kicked things off in a black
jacket but quickly ditched it revealing
this elegant dolce and gabbana gown
topping off the look with an extravagant
headpiece giving off the vibe of a very
blushing bride that makes me so happy
very fitting because the music is from
jlo's upcoming rom-com marry me which
she stars in with owen wilson and maluma
see what you want tonight's tonight
i'll be the one in the veil so does all
the wedding talk have j lo hearing
wedding bells the singer was recently
asked on the today show if the words
marry me are ones she would like to hear
in the future and here's what she said i
don't know yeah i guess
i mean i you know me i'm a romantic i
always have been i've been married a few
times
um
yeah i still believe in happily ever
after for sure of course we know lopez
and ben affleck are going strong since
rekindling their romance this past
spring after previously being engaged
from 2002 to 2004. in september a source
told et that the couple could not be
more in love adding it is like they
never broke up but everything is way
better this time we're having such a
good time in marry me j lo's character
kat is not quite as lucky in love she
learns her fiance played by maluma has
been cheating on her just moments before
she's supposed to marry him on stage
instead cat sees owen wilson's character
in the audience and makes a snap
decision
yes
[Music]
i'll marry you you
owen and j.lo first appeared together in
the 1997 thriller anaconda you're in the
middle of the jungle
okay all you guys do is you question and
you criticize and back in june e.t spoke
with the actor about reuniting it was
nice to uh
to sort of meet up with
jen after all these years and work on
marrying me and um
i think that that movie turned out
pretty well
and um
you know her character was great kind of
because she's doing a lot of
singing and uh we really had a good cast
maluma
and
a lot of good people in it as for maluma
he told et about making his feature film
debut alongside a couple of hollywood
heavyweights yeah that was an amazing
experience it was the first time that i
was part of a movie and this was a big
big deal my first movie is the hollywood
movie with all wilson and jennifer uh
lopez they both treated me so good the
whole team they knew that it was my
first project and my first movie and
well they they became a family for me
this month or these two months that we
were shooting movies
[Music]